Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Hi, With Dr. Marianne Trent about supporting aspiring psychologists, whether it's always necessary to have a master's in order
to pursue and progress your career as an aspiring psychologist. And today is my attempt to help to answer one side of that debate, really. I am going to be joined in conversation, which you can watch if you'd like to, on the Good Thinking Psychological Services YouTube channel. But you don't have to, you can just listen through this very podcast that you might be listening to right now. I'm going to be joined by a lady who works for a master's course. And now I should say that I haven't been funded or, you know, cajoled in any way to record this episode. I reached out to the course because it was a course that I had studied and that I had found really useful. So yeah, just take on board what we discuss. We're discussing the benefits mainly of doing a master's. But if you would like to talk to the other side of this
argument that maybe you think you don't need a master's to progress your career in psychology, then do please drop into my DMs or send me an email and we can absolutely discuss getting you on to talk to the other side of this debate. And similarly, if you found it useful thinking from the perspective of a mother in last week's episode about whether you can, should and what it would be like to train as a professional psychologist when you're a mother. If you'd like to discuss it from a male perspective, do let me know as well. And I hope you'll find this episode really useful and it might open your eyes to thinking about different ways of strengthening your CV and I will look forward to catching up with you at the end of this episode. Yes, I hope you find it useful and speak to you very soon.
Welcome along to Dr Mel West who joins us from Newman. Hi Mel. Hi thank you very much for having me. Thank you. I reached out to your predecessor who was Lorna because I had done the master's qualification with Newman and so when I was wanting to talk about masters you know sometimes it's better the devil you know um but I understand that you took over after Lorna is that right? That's right yes so I took over from the running the masters in 2017 it was a big thing because um Lorna set the course up and she'd been running it for a long time uh and so some big shoes to fill but I think I'm doing all right yeah. hard to give away your babies isn't it absolutely that's the thing as well yes
I think she was quite watchful over it for a while but I think I've sort of earned the trust now um and yes she obviously an absolute fountain of knowledge with so much to give having set it up um you know as a novel course and having set that up and being part of the initial thought about developing it she's given me so much information that yeah it's um enabled me to to go into it feeling quite confident um and running it successfully yeah brilliant we will hear a little bit about the novel way that your particular course is set up a little bit later but our audience is not just clinical psychologists like me our audience can be anyone really who is an aspiring psychologist or working in various different areas of psychology could
you tell us a little bit about your kind of psychology career and how you got to be where you are now please Mel. Certainly yeah so I finished my undergraduate degree and I actually didn't go straight into a master's I decided that I'd had enough and of education higher education and I needed a break and I went into finance because obviously psychology allows that with all the stats um and I have many years of working in finance and got married and had children and then we moved to a different part of the country I'd always felt I wanted to go back to it wasn't finished with psychology um but obviously once you get caught up in life it can be difficult uh so I but having moved to a different uh part of the country I'd sort of given up my job and I felt free to try something new.
So I went back to university and I actually because I had done back in those days, psychology with health studies, there wasn't health psychology back then. I had to do a PG certificate to get the conversion for the BPS graduate registration so I did that and then I went on and did my master's in health psychology and then did my PhD from that point I've been working in again higher education at different universities. Thank you so much. You know, thank you for chatting to me. We were chatting just before we went live about actually quite how unique the qualification certainly was when I was looking for it in 2006, 2007. Because when I was doing it, it was part-time distance learning in the main, but I had to kind of go a little bit in once a term for teaching and for an exam but I understand it's moved and become even more modern.
It has that's right yes we are now completely online apart from one day you come in for the induction day and that's where we talk you through you know make sure you can use the library systems make sure you can use Moodle and so you can navigate your way around the the sort of electronic sort of versions of everything and also that just enables you to meet your cohort in person and the stuff and then it's all online there are are no exams. It's just coursework. And like I said, we we are doing recorded lectures so that they're available. And then we have the chat functions where we discuss the reading and there are sort of online activities and quizzes and things. So, yeah, it's amazing how everything is done electronically yeah and I guess the pandemic has sped up that process as well absolutely yeah so obviously we
were moving towards that sort of gradually um the world generally but uh yes as the as the course was already um mostly online at that point uh it was you know um it was it was still quite novel in in that respect at that time and covid's pushed it forward and i said so now we are making it even more online and even more interactive online that's that that's the difference i'd say that's the thing before it was less it was more asynchronous and now it's becoming more synchronous because we're much more au fait if you like with doing these face-to-face sort of you know digital electronic kind of contacts which is great because we then are getting to see the students rather than see a picture of the students all the
time you guys were like 13 14 years ahead of the you know the remote working curve you you're really doing good stuff um a really common question i'm asked um all the time really um which is uh do i need a master's know, to progress my career in psychology, either clin psych, or health or forensic, you know, do I need that? Or can I do that without? And I guess that's an important kind of one for us to weigh up together. Yes, definitely is very important. I don't, I think that some people can be lucky, and you could get away without having a master's um and i think like we've said um we mentioned before briefly before we came on air that um maybe you could if there was this belief that if you had a first you could get away without doing a master's but actually i think um
it's they're so competitive the field of psychology is so competitive that actually even if you have a first uh a master's is a real benefit um because it is a step up from an undergrad even if you have got a uh first it is a higher level you know we talk about them uh in universities we talk about it yeah your first is year four, and then second year is level five, third year is level six, and then your master's is level seven. And that is a step up when you look at all the marking criteria, there's a little bit more expected. And I think that maybe employers are aware of that, and certainly within within psychology there's an awareness of that so I think you don't always need a master's you could be lucky but it's mostly advantageous. Yeah I guess what I liked about what I did and I'd said before we came on as well
people would be like I'd rather listen to what you were speaking about before it sounds good but before we came on I only did I think the postgraduate certificate because I managed to get on the doctorate after one year um and that was still really advantageous actually so I was really pleased I was still able to get a qualification for that one year but even just the rigorous way that you taught me about research and being able to comfortably take that apart pick it apart put it back together and construct my own was really useful yes yes that's right so um it's the case that it is we often have students starting they have to register for the masters anyway that's the way it kind of works at the moment um but they sort of leave after doing the first year which is three taught modules and that gives you a postgraduate
certificate or you can stay on and you might finish the the six taught modules which is the postgraduate diploma and often like I say students will start thinking they're going to finish the whole masters and then as you said you did apply thinking I'll just give it a chance the clinical doctor I'll try it and then they get a place awarded a place and so then they take the lesser award and but they always say yeah that first module in research methods really does help with that interview where you have to do tests and you have to talk about you know research and and how what kind of things are of interest and how you would go about carrying out research it's and it is designed that way that's the course is designed so that it will help with those kind of things and obviously like you said it's not
just about uh clinical psychology here it's about and it just it can help with any area of of work that you're going in any career if you want to be leading things and um especially in sort of an applied kind of setting where things might really help to do action research you might not need a formal kind of uh research project but you can do action research which is research as you go through in a real setting uh and that can really help to give you evidence of making a change that is required in any work actually. Thank you. Obviously one of the main drawbacks for any masters is that it might mean that you have to you know do less work or paid work I mean or you know in
traditionally taught masters you might not be able to do any work around it you know or you might choose not to so you can really focus on your masters and of course there are financial implications to master's study in that you have to pay tuition fees as well so it's not you know this stuff doesn't come for free and that can be really tricky when we're trying to to think about inclusion and diversity in our workforce as well are there any other subsidized or bursary ways for accessing master's funding or you know scholarships anything like that these days I think um I think some universities do offer some it's a case of looking at what uh universities have on offer because obviously most students are looking to go through student finance
and not all masters cost the same amount of money which isn't the same as undergraduates most undergraduates cost nine and a half thousand a year for studying and I think that yeah it's individual you could you could also be really lucky and get a company to sponsor you and sometimes people in the work situation do actually manage to get support from their from their employer and get the tuition fees paid but yeah it is a problem and like you say most of you have to have uh work experience the work experience isn't well paid and trying to then balance that with your very demanding masters is quite a sort of a balancing act and quite a skill that you need to develop really yeah I think that's a really good idea not one that I considered of but you could you could potentially ask your employer to help with that but certainly even if you're doing distance learning
like I was it can be really helpful if your employer is on board with giving you a little bit of study leave here and then or allowing you to work on assignments, you know, in quieter moments, you know, because it is really tricky. You know, when I was when I was with you, I had a car crash, I had a breakup, you know, I was trying to strive for new assistant posts. And, you know, it's not an easy time in my life whilst also trying to learn this stuff and get it in my head and be functional in my paid work as well. You know, we are asking a lot of our aspiring psychologists, aren't we? Yes, we really are it is um it's a most i suppose uh students are coming to us at a time you know usually in their 20s when it's there's a lot of change and there's a lot
to get to grips with and you're still developing as a person so it is a very demanding time um and yet there's a lot to to be balancing and juggling. But it's amazing how it can be pulled off. I think if you're determined and you're very well motivated, you can pull it off and you can succeed. But it is a lot to deal with, especially when you've got the finance issues as well. It's very difficult. Yes, it certainly is and uh yeah I think I was just operating on grim and gritty determination really at times during that tricky patch in my life but you know it's not I think it's important that we think about how we
balance and reduce the risk of burnout is there any guidance you'd give to master's students or potential master's students or even people that aren't considering master's for how to reduce and avoid burnout in mental health professions um yes definitely uh we cover that quite a lot on one of the second year modules actually that i run um it's a really important topic. And it's, you know, there's lots of sort of work looking into how as a profession, when in any type of therapy, it's it's a very giving profession. It takes a lot out of you. It can be quite exhausting. And yet we sort of recommend all these things to clients and yet don't take the time to do it to us and give ourselves that room. And because it's so competitive, you often find that it's breeding more competition in the workplace.
So who gets in first? Who's got the heaviest workload? Who's got the most clients? And it's not very healthy. And so we really encourage people to to reflect. Reflection is a massive part of being a psychologist. You should be able to spend time and just reflect on what's happening. How do you feel? How can you make things a bit better? I'm trying to recognise any signs of stress before it builds up because stress can build up and come upon you quite slowly and it's not until you're sort of dysfunctional that you realise how much it has affected you. So really encouraging time for self-care and finding things that help with self-care and making sure you fit it in and pushing work back
and not taking on more and trying not to get it to be pulled into that very competitive element of being a psychologist. It is tricky isn't it, I remember when I was working as an assistant psychologist and you know you're asked to do stuff and there is that expectation that you will just do it but you've already got so many other things I was working on three inpatient wards for my qualified for my assistant work it's a big job and I loved it but there is that kind of you know it's it's a it's a tricky relationship where you feel like you want to say yes and you kind of have to say yes but you don't really have enough hours in the day yes absolutely so um obviously that's it's often sold to those in lower paid jobs as
it's good experience for you why would you say no uh and yes it is good experience but you should be allocated the right time uh sort of frames to fit these in it within a uh within the workload that allows you to to feel that you're giving it everything rather than being spread so thinly you you aren't able to fully be present with anything. So I'd say it's about being boundaried. You have to, however much you're grateful for being in the role, and that's often a feeling which students sort of relay to me. They're grateful for having the role, but they wouldn't be getting that role if they weren't deserving of it. So it's about appreciating your value and putting any boundaries
in place and and showing and saying that you want yes you want the experience you're very grateful to the experience but you need to be realistic about what you can actually do yeah and that is likely to be a question on your on your applications as well you know when have you been able to say no to stuff um so it's good practice to try and put that in you know to try and give that a bash as well um you know it's very important that we're able to know our own limits and be confidently able to protect them um otherwise we will be too thinly spread and you know it will lead to burnout it will lead to long periods of sickness absence so absence and it might well lead to us wanting to leave
the profession altogether. And that's just not what anyone wants for us. No, that's exactly right. So, you know, we see all the time where burnout is sort of leading to more and more absences and people leaving the profession. And they say that actually, you know, people, young people coming into the profession are more at risk of burnout and that's because they're trying so hard and and you don't get that experience of course it's better for you to build up experience and then you're bringing more to the job but if you're leaving before you get to that point that's really sad and it's detrimental for the profession. So, yeah, I think it is very it's very important to take what you can and try to be boundary.
And like you said, it will pay. You will be asked about that. And it is something to to be proud of that you have that ability to say no. Yeah, I tried to use this podcast to spread a little bit of compassion in the psychology world as well and just to really highlight that this isn't a race you know I often say it doesn't really matter you know whether you get onto training this year or next year or the year after it might matter personally you know it might matter if you feel like you're putting your life on hold but in terms of the finished product you, what is actually better is that you get there on day one of your course and things feel within floundering and feeling like it's all too much they can't do the personal can't do the professional bit can't do the research bit because
it is you know that you and mixing socially with the cohort and juggling your life it is a lot isn't it when you're undergoing any professional psychology training and so some of the advantage of just slowing things down a bit and really making sure you're consolidating these skills, you're giving yourself opportunities to learn research, to do research, means that when you get to your chosen professional qualification route in psychology, it will feel like it's in your stride. And that is so much better. Yes, absolutely. Yes. So I hear that quite a lot. Students feel really disheartened because they can do the course over four years. So obviously, you know, some of them less are applying year after year and they're so disheartened.
And often I hear I feel like my life's on hold and I just want to get this. But like I say, it's about trying to to frame it reframe it in your mind slightly and think about well each year I'm more experienced I'm going to be bringing more to it I'm going to be able to be more comfortable in it and be able to enjoy it and it seems like a bizarre thing to say but um actually if you can enjoy it um it's you it will be so much more pleasurable as an experience and you're less likely to feel really overwhelmed. So, yes, it's about sort of accepting your capabilities at the time and then knowing that however hard you sort of want, however much you want it it's okay you will if you will get there eventually probably um or you'll get to somewhere and you'll be happy things often work out for the best uh and yeah i think it's it's a slow build-up is probably more beneficial than
going in way of feeling way over your head and then sort of feeling a bit panicky and and not comfortable so you want to have a little bit of a challenge but it's got to be a comfortable sort of push not being massively overwhelmed yeah I guess I kind of liken it to when I did my um my maths GCSE and in year 10 I did an exam um and I just found it quite tricky you know and so I really spent time looking at what I'd found tricky about that. And I asked my maths teacher for some additional help at lunchtimes, you know, once a week, because I was that kind of girl. And really, by the time my GCSE exam, final exam came, I walked out of that exam, because I'd looked at every question when I can do that,
I can do that, I can do that, I can do that. I walked out feeling like I'd absolutely given it my best shot. And that's kind of how it felt when I was doing my doctorate interviews, is that they asked me questions. And even if they're a bit left field, I still felt like I could give a good answer. And I think that's the difference. That's what time and consolidation and kind of focused attention can be can be really useful for absolutely yeah so that's it it's like that's the that's the sort of epitome of it isn't it you sort of building up that experience and the more you experience you have in all aspects of your life the more you're bringing to that interview or job role and that's going to be beneficial not just for you and and how you perform as a
professional in that role but also to any clients that you have you're going to be able to bring more to it because you are sort of have a much wider sort of experience and more to bring to it so so yeah I think that's exactly right it is about just being aware that it's all experiences are good to you and they they say don't know if it doesn't kill you it makes you stronger which is a bit of a you know maybe a little bit controversial but it does mean that you have more to offer and that can be really good for clients. Yeah, we definitely don't want to be suggesting that. No, no, sorry. No, I absolutely know what you mean.
You know, it's being able to reframe your think when I was studying my doctorate, even there was teachings that we'd had about, about people that had been scarred as part of their experiences. And it's that sense of, you only get a scar if you've survived. And that's really powerful as an idea. So it is basically that if it doesn't kill you then you know that's a good thing um but it's how you then speak about that isn't it and even within difficult interviews um challenging interviews they will often want to know how you've coped in adversity and how you've gone through that and we need to be well practiced in doing that and also demonstrating that it's okay to have had adversity you know you want we
want well-rounded people in psychology we definitely don't want machines no that's exactly right yeah so it is about well it comes back to reflection doesn't it and i was saying the importance of reflection earlier um it's it is a key sort of function within a profession a psychology a professional um and you are it's about thinking about what that event meant to you that adversity that you've experienced and we all have um and it's you know like we say it's an important thing to survive um an adversity and to come out of it and think about what that means what it means um and how do you take it forward and what can you do with it in a positive light um and yeah that will obviously benefit clients you because you can relate to things and you can talk about experiences more
um and yeah just that more to offer really definitely um are masters generally still kind of roll on roll off in september or can you kind of roll on at different points of the academic year just i'm thinking people are listening to this now they're thinking is now the time you know do i apply now or when is the best time or the only time to apply for master's study? I think now universities are trying to get this sort of much more flexible approach to applying and starting. But in my own experience, I'm not aware of any that are currently actually starting other than in September. We start only in September. And applications for Masters, they're not the same as for undergraduates. You know, in undergraduates, you're applying the year before, really. But for Masters, you can still be applying in July
and be expecting to start in September. So you can have a good long think about it also I would just say that it's probably worth putting in an application anyway you know just put in an application and you can think about whether or not you do want to start often you can defer your start but yeah I think because of the way masters are structured with modules taught in a certain order at a certain time that it's not always as flexible as being able to start at different times maybe that's next for the the sort of novel yes roll on roll off masters you know here when you're ready and what's the deal with actual applications is that like a form is an interview? What tends to be the application route?
Well, different universities do different things. For us, it's just a form. We just have a form. It's not that much. And I would say, actually, when you're writing your personal statement, we don't we don't always want to read that this is all you've ever wanted to do and so it's nice when people are just open and honest and say you know that they're hard working and well motivated and that's enough we don't need pages and pages of that you've always wanted to do it and how and demonstrating how this is the case um it's enough to just say that you really want to do this now and you're really well motivated oh you just made me flash back to my um my undergraduate uh personal statement and honestly I found a copy of it not so long ago it was dreadful it was like talking about stuff like oh me and my brother get on quite well like why was that in there who was not helping me how did I get on to a course I'm now much better at writing personal statements
but honestly so yeah it's very interesting to think about what should and should not be in your personal statement yes absolutely yes uh It is funny sometimes reading them. And I think most people will look back and sort of think, oh. But I think sometimes there's a couple of sentences, well, a paragraph and a half maybe says more than enough. And yes, it's about making it directly relevant, which is all of it. That's a key to all academic writing really lovely um thank you so much for joining me mel is there anything that we i haven't asked you or that you wanted to talk about that we haven't done so far um not really no just um we're talking about sort of inclusivity uh and diversity and just how that's really
important to make that much uh much better within psychology generally that's a that's a really important point and hopefully um yeah the barriers are coming down and we're making it better but that's just something to just acknowledge i think it's important that we all acknowledge that um definitely that's all we've got more coming up in the podcast about inclusion and diversity and equality as well but thank you so much for joining me it's been so lovely um connecting with you um and just wishing you a lovely summer um yeah and let me know if I can help with anything in future that's lovely thank. Thank you very much. Thanks for having me. Thank you so much for listening. And thank you so much to our guest, Dr. Mel West. I have found it really, really interesting.
And like I said at the beginning, if you'd like to talk to the other side of this debate, if you think there are other ways to strengthen your CV without needing to do a master's, then do let me know. And we can also talk about that. If you've got any other ideas for podcast episode content, do let me know. And we also, as a little sneak scoop, we've got an exclusive episode coming where I answer any questions for you. It's going to be an Ask Marianne anything special. So if you have got any questions and you'd like to record yourself asking me them, then do let me know.
And there's details for how you can record testimonials or questions in the show notes. You can listen to all back episodes of the podcast by checking them out on Spotify, on Amazon, on Apple Podcasts, and you can also listen to all of them on YouTube as well. And basically, I believe anywhere you could envisage or dream of accessing podcasts, you can reach us as well, which includes Google. And yeah, Deezer, I think there's one called Deezer. Yes, you can reach me there too. We've had a lovely, successful spring and summer in the Aspiring Psychologist membership. Lots of people within the membership have this year gained places onto clinical psychology courses. And they said that they found that the membership had really helped to support them and to help them perform optimally in the interviews. We've had a couple
of people who wish to carry on in the membership as well, even though they are going to be trainee clinical psychologists. So that is just the most wonderful feedback. though they are going to be trainee clinical psychologists so that is just the most wonderful feedback if you would like to rub shoulders not only with myself but with other aspiring psychologists and also other trainee clinical psychologists or maybe if you are a trainee psychologist and you would welcome some more support some more compassionate guidance and some more thinking about enhancing developing your personal professional and research skills then do get yourself onto the aspiring psychologist waiting list and we've got some exciting developments coming for you to be able to practice and improve your skills and your chances of being published as well in research
within the membership. You've got to be on the waiting list for when the space is next open on the 1st of July. So details of how to do that can be accessed via my link tree, which is available from all of my socials. Do come and connect with me on my socials. Basically, I'm Dr. Marianne Trent on pretty much everywhere. So I'm that on Twitter. I'm that on LinkedIn. I keep getting LinkedIn and link tree mixed up. I'm that on Instagram. I'm Marianne Trent on Facebook and also Good Thinking Psychological Services Facebook and YouTube Good Thinking Psychological Services so honestly if you haven't yet stumbled across me on social media I'm also on TikTok for Dr Marianne Trent too then I don't know how you've done it you know you must live in a social media, which is probably very good for your mental health.
So long may that last. But yeah, we do some lovely stuff in the membership. And of course, there's the upcoming Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. know someone who is currently training on the Hull, the special Hull York scheme that takes you from undergraduate to the doctorate in clinical psychology. I'd love to be able to include a story from someone in that position within the upcoming Aspiring Psychologist membership. So if you know someone who fulfills that brief, then do let them know about me. And similarly, if you know someone or perhaps you are someone who has trained initially, perhaps done your undergraduate, maybe done your master's in a different country and then come across to the UK to pursue your professional qualification. Perhaps you've even got on to a professional qualifying course, but English wasn't your first language or you weren't born in the UK.
I'd love to be able to include a couple of stories from your perspective within the Aspiring Psychologist book too, which is hopefully going to be published at the start of October. Thank you so much for listening right to the end. Let me know if you've got any questions or if you'd like to record your question for me for the special Q&A episode. I'm going to drop in the Q&A jingle here just, you know, because I've got it. It's ready. I'm excited, you know I love a jingle, thank you so much for being part of my world, and take care of yourselves, be kind to you. ask her anything questions and answers
questions and answers questions and answers with Dr. Mary Trent If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the As the Clinical
Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.